you were working on this biopic of
Freddie Mercury and I mean you worked on
it for six years yeah the whole thing
fell apart the band Queen wanted to
clean it up and you wanted to get into
the Nitty Gritty right yes
what is the nitty gritty mean like you
wanted to get into his sex life yeah
definitely I mean there are amazing
stories about Freddie Mercury you know
crazy crazy
the guy was wild I mean he was living an
extreme lifestyle that debauchery
debauchery I mean there you know there
are stories of you know I don't know
what you call them that little people
what is the table little people with you
know plates with cocaine on their heads
walking around party
Odyssey but you got to remember and I
understand it they are a band they want
to protect their legacy as a band they
want it to be about Queen and I fully
understand so why didn't you have that
discussion with them upfront
my first meeting I should have never
carried on because a member of the band
I won't say who said ima I won't say
yeah
but he said you know this is such a
great movie because it's got such an
amazing thing happens in the middle of
the movie uh-huh
like Oh what happens in the middle of
the movie because uh you know Freddie
dies
I go all right I got all right so you
mean it's a bit like pulp fiction you
know the end is the middle in the middle
is yet I go that's really nice a wild
that's a wild movie all right that's
interesting never thought about like
it's no no no normal movie okay so every
what happens in the second half of the
movie he said well you know we see how
the band carries on from strength to
strength and I said listen I go not one
person is going to see a movie with that
where the lead character dies from AIDS
and then you carry on that would be just
the craziest movie guys guys we've got a
carry on just wait till you see the
movie I do about you Howard
haha